[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to let's
talk about how Marvel movies are
destroying cinema yes they may be fun
and exciting with good characters comedy
drama and action and yes they've allowed
us to bring what we thought we couldn't
bring to the big screen and people that
are so familiar they almost feel like
cinematic family to us now but there's
just too many of them some of them I
dare even say are not great out of their
twenty hit movies they came out in the
past ten years four of them were kind of
mad I'd even go so far as to say it's
not like we went through a Dark Age of
cinema where the majority of films were
creatively and emotionally bankrupt it's
not like Marvel movies are anything
compared to those masterpieces I'm sorry
I like Marvel I get why it's popular to
argue they're repetitive and there's too
many of them and sure a lot of them are
even that bad arguments but even before
the MCU Hollywood was running on
creative fumes imagination and good
storytelling was kind of a rarity and
they were still repeating the same ideas
and stories just in really shitty ways
normal isn't perfect but it's constantly
entertaining and constantly turning out
much better films than that Dark Age of
cinema I mentioned earlier
I'd much rather watch the worst of
Marvel with at least their charming main
characters than the majority of what
came out for years and years the reason
I bring this up is to show that I am a
giant Marvel Cinematic Universe fan but
there is one criticism that everybody
makes that I tend to agree with - the
villain suck
it's funny how Disney the current owners
of the MCU have turned out some of the
greatest cinematic villains in history
yet in recent years they've been hitting
some duds Marvel I guess fittingly
enough is the same way ever since their
first hit with Iron Man the villains
have always been not awful but
underwhelming they're boring
uninteresting kind of silly and even
when they're given a good backstory or
reason to be evil they just seem
unpatient
now don't get me wrong the comics they
come from usually have a lot of great
emotional development as well as
interesting story threads but the movies
despite doing a lot of other things very
well never seem to reflect that even
when Samuel Jackson was trying to defend
Marvel he had to hand victory over to DC
when it came to the villains DC will you
have interesting bad guys
it seems that again like recent Disney
the focus seems to be on making the main
characters more interesting and complex
which many people would agree is
probably the more important element and
yes there is an irony that early on
Disney properties seem to be focused on
making the villains more charming and
complex while the title characters seem
secondary in terms of interest or
passion but of course the focus should
be making the hero and the villain
equally interesting this is admittedly
tough though especially when for years
people didn't take your medium seriously
comic-book movies are big hits now but
for a while they were seen as box-office
poison
nobody wanted to make them they were
seen as kid stuff too corny so not only
did focus have to be on the hero having
emotional substance that can be taken
seriously but it had to be done and not
just one film but a lot of films to show
this is a genre worth paying attention
to so for a long time we got forgettable
antagonists usually what complicated
plans very little personality often just
a dull stick in the hood despite many of
them being played by good actors they
never left the impact that made their
original characters so engaging meadows
except for loki everyone seemed to like
loki despite him being and let's be fair
here often pathetic he looks silly
nothing goes his way he's constantly
outwitted and his motivation might be
the weakest out of any of the villains
he just wants attention
with that said that is a very relatable
motivation therefore we do always feel
empathy for how things never go his way
and on top of that he's just funny for a
while he was the only Marvel villain who
smiled he enjoyed being the trickster
the manipulator the one that made
everybody's life in them notches hell I
think
a lot of us can connect with that joy
that ties to our inner troublemaker
doing something wrong to get something
that you want outside of Loki though
Marvel offered very little that stood
out honestly if you asked me who was the
second most intimidating threat in the
early run of these movies I'd say Garry
Shandling whispering hail Hydra
that's how unimpressive things got with
such an impressive lineup many thought
that the presentation of Thanos
the ultimate villain had been built up
for several movies was never gonna
deliver on what was being promised but
then somewhere around 2017 things
started to change in guardians of the
galaxy - we got Kurt Russell as ego he
was a surprisingly good villain
then in spider-man homecoming we got
Michael Keaton as vulture another
surprisingly good villain thinking thor
ragnarok would keep Blanchette as hella
along with Jeff Goldblum as the
Grandmaster Black Panther with Michael B
Jordan as kill monger and finally
infinity war with Josh Brolin as the
long-awaited Thanos that's five movies
in a row helped six if you count ant-man
and wasp that delivered strong
interesting passionate funny
unforgettable villains that finally
seemed on par for some of our most
iconic heroes suddenly six movies in a
row the antagonist was just as much fun
to watch as the protagonist so what
happened
you
[Music]
[Laughter]
how did these baddies go from miss after
Miss to hit after hit what were these
villains doing that these villains
weren't I don't think it's one specific
thing but I do think all of them have
several elements in common and I'm not
lying fangirls I think they're all
elements that you could tie back to
Logan yep all the ingredients that made
these baddies so memorable all took a
page from Loki's cookbook and before I
go any further is probably worth saying
the let's take a look at guardians of
the galaxy to ego throughout the
majority of the film he is a likable guy
he's a jokester he's a visionary he's a
go-getter
for him you can get anything you want if
you just try hard enough like Loki he
was the only one who started smiling
enjoying what he did thus we enjoyed
watching him he's easy to like which
makes it all the more heartbreaking when
you find out what a psycho he truly is
and serves also as a cautionary tale
about who you can trust
even if it's a parent this lesson
wouldn't be nearly as dramatic if we
didn't enjoy watching him as much as we
did in spider-man homecoming we got a
lower-middle-class worker who was
screwed by Stark Industries and the
government leaving his job in life in
the dust like Loki he was overlooked and
forgotten and wanted what he felt was
owed to him his relatability comes from
the idea that he's a common working guy
so much so that's an absolute shock when
you see just how common he is switching
back and forth between prom chauffeur
and murdering mastermind showcases how
little the laws of human life can be
it's like a common job to him
demonstrating his creep value in thor
ragnarok we get a bandage sister Thor
never knew existed like Loki she looks
extravagant enjoys her evil side and can
even get out a good one-liner here and
there but let's be honest Loki looks far
more fabulous and feminine green outfits
she can be funny but she can also be
quite menacing not just in how
physically powerful she is but also her
over-the-top demeanor and killing
someone look at that face that is
hardcore on the other end as a comedic
overlord who wishes to entertain while
also being entertained himself he's kind
of like the ultimate couch potato just
sitting around in his robe except the
shows he watches are real people and he
cares nothing if they live or die
again with both of these villains
there's a strange attraction to having
so much power you can just do whatever
you like and act however you want to act
going as big and crazy as you want just
in different ways of course pushing to
the point of hurting is and people is
what separates us from siding with them
but still their underlying enthusiasm
for what they do is addictive to watch
in Black Panther the opposite approach
is taken kill monger wasn't one of the
most serious villains the Marvel movies
have ever thrown at us like low-key and
vulture he feels abandoned and ignored
with what should be his but that goes
even deeper than that
kill monger knows there's a great power
not being utilized in a way that can
help millions rather than use it for
peaceful purposes he uses it to go to
war figuring obtaining peace through
force is the way to go well this idea is
similar to many other Marvel villains we
see the harsh environment that kill
macGruber up him how far he had to come
to achieve his goal and understand why
he's been so tainted most of us wouldn't
do what he's done but we understand why
he's doing it we feel why he's doing it
mostly because it's not just told to us
it's shown to us he's the outsider to
Wakanda even though he's the rightful
heir his inner city way of speech is
completely different from the almost
Shakespearean way people in Wakanda
speak but they're both just as big an
epic we see him start off quiet almost
sneaking under the radar in fact the
brilliance of this villain is at first
we don't even know he is the main
villain
it looks more like it's gonna be Andy
Serkis his character but that's the idea
he appears to be an above-average
henchman that turns out to be the
biggest threat what Conda has ever seen
thus you not only admire his stealth but
also his strategy he starts off quiet
and deadly but becomes loud and
larger-than-life his motivations might
seem similar button is unique and
relatable all of us leads up to the
Ultimate Marvel villain at least the one
the movies were building up as the
ultimate Marvel villain familes
fan OHS was almost the perfect reversal
of what the Marvel villains have been in
the past because he went from being the
second main focus next to the lead to
the main focus now it's could be seen as
a problem except in a movie like
infinity war with tons of main
characters like tons of main characters
it only makes
that the main thread should be the link
that ties them all together with more
characters in this one that any of the
other Avengers movies they knew they had
to deliver what they spent over six
years building up Thanos is the closest
to what the Disney films used to do
making the villain the most interesting
and complex but with infinity war it
doesn't hurt any of the main characters
focus because we already know them so
well we've had tons and tons of movies
getting to know them thus all the
simpleness complexity subtleties and
extremes could all be explored with the
villain Thanos feels life in the
universe has gotten too out of control
with violence war and death so he goes
the mathematical route and aims to wipe
half of it out of existence yeah kind of
a similar motivation with other lesser
Marvel villains but everything from what
he says and how he says it to the way he
carries himself makes us understand who
he is and why he's doing what he's doing
and it's all fascinating there was a
little joy in what he does but he acts
like a man who used to experience joy
it's still in there but only after he
carries out his mission can he
experience it again everything about him
is bittersweet a man who has gone
through a lot of pain and knows he will
go through even more but believes it's
truly for the greater good he tries to
separate himself from love and desire in
the hopes of achieving what he feels
needs to be done but you can see in
everything that he does that it's still
buried deep inside him to a point where
sacrificing the last person that truly
means anything to him breaks his heart
yet he still does it he doesn't have to
say anything to express the complex
emotions he's going through it's all
just right there on his face there's
also a confidence in what he does and
unshaken truth that what he is doing is
the only salvation and again it's all
brought out through the performance and
the effects that make him so interesting
to watch everything he does you follow
and understand even if you disagree with
it to go from Marvel villains being an
obstacle for the interesting hero to
overcome to a villain being the most
interesting character in an already
massive lineup of interesting characters
is quite an
accomplishment so yeah all these Marvel
villains have come a long way but what
was it that changed what was it that we
saw in Loki early on that we're now
seeing in the current Marvel villains
well looking these recent foes over I
think it comes down to four elements
relatability not being told but being
shown how the villains motivation
connects to their unique personality
charm we have to experience empathy for
the villain and that comes from either
laughing with them feeling sorry for
them or both uniqueness something has to
be different about the villain to
separate him or her from the rest and it
can't just be the look stain would
probably say and do something similar to
what Kross would do but kill monger
would definitely do something different
from what ego would do and finally focus
a hero can be important but as the
saying goes a hero can only be as strong
as his or her villain Batman is amazing
but he wouldn't be as good without the
Joker Luke Skywalker is great but his
journey would be lessened without Darth
Vader it's when you take time to show
respect for the problem that we can
appreciate the magnitude of the solution
thus showing the complexity and
importance of your villain magnifies the
complexity and importance of your hero
one of the greatest tragedies of Iron
Man two is that the villain is actually
pretty cool
he has a great back story great
motivation great look and a great actor
to bring him to life but little to
nothing is done with him we wanted to
see him take on Iron Man we wanted to
see him completely manipulate and
outsmart the worthy adversary but sadly
we got very little him and he fell
completely wasted so what do you think
will this list of great Marvel villains
continue in the MCU Oh Ant Man and wasp
that came out after infinity war has
some enjoyable baddies but again by
their own terms it was funny and comical
but still emphasized the motivation and
pain behind the main antagonist so even
in a more comedic setting they can still
do this pretty well outside of that we
can only hope this great lineup of
Marvel villains continues to be
represented yeah it sucks it took so
long to finally get them right but at
least they finally are now and we still
have a ton of really entertaining movies
that
didn't always have the best villains it
isn't the villain sucked and the movie
sucked too Marvel Comics is not short of
great characters and just because some
of them are bad guys doesn't mean
they're not as important or interesting
they deserve just as much focus and
complexity as the heroes do there's such
a major part of what makes a story so
interesting and memorable but as long as
the villains are continuing to be
written with these four elements in mind
Marvel will not only continue to give us
the heroes we've grown to love but the
villains we've loved to hate I'm gonna
stop Critic I remember it so you don't
have to
[Music]
[Applause]
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out in this week we are doing a
Piscopo relief Episcopal relief
facilitates healthier more fulfilling
lives and communities struggling with
hunger poverty disaster and disease
their local communities on the ground
allow them to work in places where few
others remain for the long haul and to
deliver life improving result in
innovative ways and techniques they
collaborate with communities around the
world to create authentic lasting
results that can be sustained by the
communities themselves their
international partnerships addresses
challenges in remote communities around
the world as well as in urban
environments where extreme poverty
persists if you look at their site in
their YouTube channel you can see all
the various ways they grow communities
to where they need to be and where they
deserve to be and the wonderful people
young and old they help along the way
click on the link and see how you can
help so many people and communities grow
stronger with every day
[Music]
you